- [Narrator] There's a
ramen shop on Rishiri Island
off the northern tip of Japan.
To get there from Tokyo,
fly two hours to Sapporo.
From there, take the train to Wakkanai,
the northernmost city in Japan.
You then catch a ferry to Rishiri Island.
Make your way to the
western part of the island,
and once you're there
let's hope you're on time.
It's only open two and a half hours a day.
But the trip is worth it
because the place is said
to have some of the best
ramen in all of Japan.
When it comes to ramen in Japan,
there are a few places
whose names will draw people
from all around the world.
Ramen Miraku is one such place.
And visitors come for this
special charred soy ramen
made with local kombu seaweed broth.
- [Narrator] And this is no instant ramen.
Making the dish takes hours.
- [Narrator] The question, of course:
Why do you think people come all this way?
- [Narrator] Our turn.
One charred ramen, please.
(slurping)
- [Narrator] Oh wow, this is good.
(upbeat music)